Haa,
this is the padi Face Ode,
this is Alpha Thirty s, answer me,
this is it.
Oh, oh
, what's that just now? I'm going to vomit the bass
.  Music]
It's been 5 years since I've been killing time, but the
target doesn't seem to
be there. I don't have it.
I don't
want me yeah yeah yeah I got a car tee ana target cub yeah yeah yeah
I think it's been a long time since I've been working, so this level is good then
beach The
ring isn't there to satisfy you guys
The arm of our Kurunsu captain  If goo
w
We won't let the latecomers wait here We'll move to the
next mission The next mission is a tool
I want to protect you
aname
[music]
ani
ban
me
[music]
aname red wata
me
[music]
ni
me
ha
[music]
[applause]
Hurry up and go to school  It's the first time in my life that I wanted to do it.I felt like I
was suffocating while I was in the hospital.But
Yuu-chan, you should take a little more
rest.You can't even take notes with your arms
.  Come on,
everything's going to be all right Oh no,
what the hell are those women's eyes on your heart
? Is this the new security guard?  What is it?
Ah, I protected you, right? Ah
, 5 people a year
.
It's clear that the men and women we killed aren't normal people.
We belong to an organization called the Union.
No, I'm just an experimental body to complete successful works like jf and mari At
first, I couldn't even do this much Ah,
but as time goes by, only me and m 24 undergo a special evolution for some reason.  I said I accomplished
it Compared to the successful work, it's like a piece of junk in the rear I do
n't know how many others are saying that it's an experiment similar to yours No read I'm the only
one who
survived  If you don't have a destination, you should live here
. You went against the organization
.  But it's all thanks to you and your friends
Of course if you want to go out you can go out
I'm not going to lock
you up Are you
serious?  No,
what's important is the master's decision,
so it's not free I
was just thinking about increasing the number of staff
Pop-poo ranks are going to come in. Are you sure you're going to carry out that thing you shared last night?
Good morning.  It's been a long time,
Amuro, I'm going to make my wish come true Jamiah
[music]
ana
[music] With
Hikkun, who has a quick ear How long have you been
[music]
What
's wrong with me?
After all, I want to scribble
[Music]
What is this?
pee
[music]
Say something, don't always use your smartphone in class
8 minutes
[music]
Eat thunder 7
Wait for the extra minutes and do that again okay
It's over!  I'm going to
come to my house if
it's all right.
Hey,
you don't have that.
How was your first day at work?
I don't have
any
particular thoughts.
Ting
This world has really
changed The time the master was asleep
was not short
You won't take a wrong turn, and you
'll be allowed to take a
detour of your soul.
Good luck with your work
Evil
Spirit Uncle In the future, it's just a smartphone, isn't it?
Oh, I
'll turn
you into a smartphone, and I'll make you a smartphone master.
Letters support
the dissolution of
Uniukon
th
master
, but somehow the feeling of e-mail is good
.
I wonder if he's a good person Do you
trust him that much?
Bright hair is worth it Baked love
[music]
regard
I don't want to be your friend
I can't move, let go of the roof
Vehicle entry is prohibited here.
Can you please
me,
get out of here, oh,
yeah, yeah,
Semei's book that Semei entrusted to a man and a woman is ha ha
Yu-chan, that woman was going to be your majesty, right
?  Before joining
Whew
[music]
I
'm fine,
that's
all.
Let's train our body so that it can't do it Yes,
yes
Mia, who's confused Mia I
'm jealous You've come this far You've gone too far
l Ride well
10 minutes
wh
Wool is good
Look at
me Are you inciting me?
Give the students a bounty, yeah, yeah,
people are a little bad,
Panas ah, ah, ah, ah,
the good-natured person who danced, was beautiful with a good body
Don't make me say it again and again, tell me to
talk
Send
me a pict Bosure car ah ah ah [music] me
If no one had seen me, I
would have died a lot.
[music]
We were born inside a transparent glass tube There's
no use in
living  It's a good name to call
them, they accept me while I'm still alive
[music],
but everyone was desperately trying to live
, just like the ordinary people who live in this town
Someday we'll look for our names, including the names of our
dead friends
.
Let's take it easy in low orbit every
time  It probably
doesn't matter, but there's something I have to do I have
to make
a promise to my friends Is
it someone who put
me here What are you saying
?  I think I
understand why Furstar decided to put him here.
m 24 I
promise I'll always fulfill my promise Until that day,
let's calm down as usual.
Rampaging Lottegee The next
mission is to strike a terrorism wreath without the warlords Civil engineering
Air  It's like I don't know what to do, little sister
who was in the middle of the day.
Until I obey And
if it's a mysterious reservation, it
will become the universe I
think it's me [music]
paron
l pet here
[music]
ana
[applause]
[music]
me
ana
can you do
[music]
me
good good good
[music]  music]
ah ah ah